MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
DANNY HERMES: Hi, everyone I'm
Danny Hermes with the commerce
team here in Google Developer
Relations.
I'm a developer programs
engineer.
I'm missing my teammate Amanda
this week, but I wanted to
talk to you guys about a new
feature we just launched
called Clicks Data
for Paid Clicks.
So as you can see on my screen
here, in the documentation for
accessing product data, we have
in the performance block
a list of data points,
sc:datapoint attributes.
And in these attributes you
actually get back a date and
clicks, and that's something
that you had already gotten,
but in addition you also get
paid underscore clicks.
So the datapoint attribute has
three XML attributes, date
clicks, and paid clicks that
actually tells you on that
given date the number of nonpaid
and the number of paid
clicks you had.
And to request this, you
can see the URI--
content dot googleapis dot com
slash content slash V1, then
your Merchant Center ID,
then slash item slash
product slash schema.
And then from there, you
can append the query
parameters you like.
So performance dot start is the
query parameter that tells
you the first date for
performance data, and
performance dot end is telling
you the second date.
Now we'll see in a bit how to
actually use the PHP client
library to get this data.
We talked about Python and .NET
the last time we met, so
I figured we'd change
it up a bit.
We're actually going to
run the PHP in the PHP
Interpreter, which should
be nice to see.
But before we do that, let's
actually head over to the
interactive demo tool to have
that just abstract away
everything for us and we can
just go ahead and click.
So let me increase the
size a little bit.
So I'm already signed in here
with my account, and I have my
merchant ID here--
10962361.
And so in order to perform the
request I want, I'm simply
going to go to the Get panel
within the Items panel--
the Get subpanel, that
is-- and I'll check
the Performance box.
And by doing that, it's going
to include 2012 dash 08 dash
9, or August 9 of this year,
as the start date, and 2012
dash 08 dash 16 as
the end date.
So what I'm going to be doing is
asking for all my products.
As far as I know, I have two
products in this account, and
I'm asking for the performance
data in this given range.
Now I'll tell you, you'll
be a bit disappointed.
I have no clicks as far as I
know, so we'll see though, but
we're really just looking to
see how the attributes are
used and how they are returning
the request.
So before I submit Execute
Notice, the URI is again
constructed in the exact same
fashion as we saw, with a
little bit of a line spill over
there to the second half.
OK, so let's execute it.
So the request gets sent, and
now it has come back.
So the response is a 200.
We see here there were 25 items
per page and the actual
number returned is just
going to be two.
In this first item, SKU124,
I do indeed have this
performance block here, and in
it I have eight data points
and that is the data points
for the days from
August 9 to August 16.
And you see here, each datapoint
has clicks equals
zero and paid clicks
equals zero.
Now before I move
on to PHP, I'll
submit one other request--
and this is to give some context
for something I'll be
talking about a bit later--
but you can also submit the same
request using the same
query parameters but for
a specific item.
So rather than just querying
your entire inventory asking
for performance and getting
back performance for--
we sell one item but there's
actually a second item in this
response as well--
but you can target performance
for specific items.
So here I've actually hard coded
in the SKU, the actual
product ID online--
:EN for English, :US for the
country, and then :SKU123 for
the SKU of the product.
And I can execute this request,
and rather than
getting a feed of products back
with this performance
data, I will get an individual
product.
So entry equals--
and again, I have this
performance block with the
eight datapoints in it for
that particular item.
So let's actually write some
code to access this data.
How can we do it?
So let me switch to Terminal,
and let's go
full screen on this.
I'm not sure what the
adjustment is.
OK, there we go.
Sorry about that.
So for security reasons I've
already loaded a token in.
I didn't want to actually go
through the whole process of
putting in my password,
et cetera.
But once we already
have the token--
the variable token--
we're going to actually
import the library.
So I'm in a folder that has the
PHP library in it, and the
PHP library is just called
GShoppingContent.php, so we
require that one.
Now using that, the GSC_Client
class is defined, so we're
going to get our own client for
making requests from an
instance of this class.
So we'll just say client equals
new GSC_Client, because
we're instantiating a new
object, and we instantiate it
with the ID for my account--
10962361, as we saw.
Now, again, since I already
have a token, rather than
going through Auth, I'm just
going to explicitly set the
token on the client using
the set token method.
So now we have a client that is
authenticated and ready to
make requests, so we want to
actually do a get request for
the items in my account.
So we need a few attributes to
make this request, so first we
need maxResults.
Now, maxResults--
we know we have two items,
so we'll just say
maxResults equals 2.
In addition, we actually
need a startToken.
Since we're not going to use any
particular startToken, we
just need it null.
But as we'll see, the signature
for the get products
method on the client object
actually needs a startToken
argument into the function
signature.
And this is sort of an artifact
of trying to keep
libraries in sync between
Python and PHP.
Python has this concept of
keyword arguments but PHP
doesn't, so we have to have a
null argument kind of in the
middle, but that's
life, right?
So of course after we have
maxResults and startToken,
we'll have our performance
start, which was 2012 dash 08
dash 09, August 9, and
our performance end--
virtually the same
thing, but--
2012 dash 08 dash 16.
These are both strings.
So now to get a feed of products
back as we saw in the
actual demo tool, I'm going to
get the variable product feed,
and I'll just call the
getProducts method on the
client, and I'm going to pass in
the four variables that we
just defined.
So first, maxResults, and
then startToken, then
performanceStart, then
performanceEnd.
So this is actually making a
request, sending it off to the
API, and giving us back the
results in the product feed.
OK, great.
So now we actually want to
examine the products and get
back the specific attributes,
particularly the datapoints,
within that object so we can
actually use them and inspect
them and maybe change some
campaigns, change the product
description, et cetera-- just
react based on the actual
traffic that the product
is getting based on the
performance data.
So I'm just going to
grab the first guy.
So from the product feed, I'll
call the method getProducts.
Now, this is a method on the
feed itself that actually will
return an object--
excuse me, a list of the
products contained in the
feed, so it's an array object.
And I'm just going to get the
first element in that list at
the zero index.
Sorry about that.
I'm not sure--
productFeed, getProducts.
There's a syntax error
somewhere, though I'm not sure
where it is.
I'm not sure where that syntax
error was, but it's gone away.
Cool.
Sorry about that.
So now I have the product from
the feed, from the very first
product contained in the list.
So to see which product that is
let's echo the title of the
product back to the terminal.
So on the product I'm going to
call the getTitle method, and
I'll echo that along with a
new line so we don't have
spill over.
So this product is called Beep,
and I had two products,
as you may have seen
in the drop down.
One was a widget and the other
one was called Beep.
So on Beep, we actually want
to get the datapoints.
So in the variable datapoints,
we'll call the datapoints
getter from the product
object--
so, getDatapoints will return
a list, hopefully, of the
eight data points that we
are expecting to get.
And it's a special
kind of list--
it's a DOMNode list, and this is
a native PHP data type, so
the way we're retrieving them
is actually a bit different
than just using square brackets
in the index.
We're actually going to have to
use the item getter on the
DOMNode list.
So now we have datapoints
[INAUDIBLE]
what datapoints is
a DOMNode list.
I'm going to print it.
There you see--
DOMNode list object.
So how many datapoints do we
have before we actually get in
and inspect some of them?
So datapoints length will tell
us the number of datapoints
that we've received, and we
expect to have received eight.
So there you have
it-- datapoints
length has eight items.
So let's get the
first one, OK?
So set the variable datapoint
equal to the datapoint at
index zero.
So to retrieve that, we just
say datapoint equals
datapoints, and then we call the
item method on datapoints
and pass in the index we want--
in this case, like I
said, zero.
So this datapoint is now a
separate kind of DOM element,
and this is an element that we
can pass to our product, and
our product has some
special getters--
getDatapointClicks,
getDatapointPaidClicks, and
getDatapointDate--
that we can actually use to
inspect the datapoint itself,
this datapoint relative
to that product.
Remember, we actually
retrieve datapoints
from the product itself.
So to find the actual date of
this datapoint, let's call
product getDatapointDate, and
we'll pass in the datapoint,
and hopefully it'll
echo back the date
for that first datapoint.
So the first datapoint is
the first date that we
expect, August 9.
Now to get the clicks
back-- not the
paid clicks but clicks--
we change the date in that
method called getDatapointDate
to just clicks.
So again, we're going to echo
product, getDatapointClicks,
and we're going to pass
in the datapoint.
Sorry, it's boring-- my product
has zero clicks.
Nobody clicked on
that product.
And similarly instead of clicks,
we will add in the
keyword paid in that method
and call the product
getDatapointPaidClicks method,
and we'll again see zero.
So this is pretty simple.
We already have support for this
in Python, .NET, and, of
course, PHP, as you just saw.
If you'd like to use this data
within your production
systems, it's ready
to go right now.
So with that, I'm going to
return to the moderator queue.
Let me pull this up for
everyone to see.
Actually, I don't know
the link to it off
the top of my head.
So the first question on the
moderator queue is--
let me get these pulled up.
Sorry, one second.
OK.
So from Andrew in Sunnyvale--
it appears that we can get
performance data on individual
products and also on the
account as a whole.
Is there a way to get data on
many products at once without
sending many individual
requests?
Now, this question is sort of
interpreted in a few different
ways, so I'll answer the many
different interpretations.
So the first interpretation that
I initially thought this
was asking was, can we get more
than 250 items with just
performance data and
nothing else?
So, currently no--
the only way to get performance
data is with the
entire payload of the
products themselves.
And this is something we're
thinking about changing or
implementing as a feature, so
if people are interested in
getting just performance data
without the rest of the
payload, please let us know.
Vote it up on our shopping
API's issue list.
We're happy to take that into
consideration when we're
developing new features.
The second meaning of this,
which is probably more
accurate to what he was asking,
is rather than just
doing a blind get and saying
give me 250 results, can we
specify which products
we're looking for
performance data for?
And the answer to that is,
yes-- luckily, this is
implemented already.
As I found when I was reviewing
this moderator
queue, this isn't really
documented very well and I'm
going to work to fix that.
But the Gdata protocol, the
underlying protocol that makes
this API work, actually
has a way to submit
queries within batches.
So we're just used to submitting
inserts, updates,
and deletes within our batches,
but we can also
submit queries.
And to submit a query, just like
a delete, you just have
an entry with an ID and then
the batch operation, and
that's it when you
submit a delete.
By the same token, if you want
to submit a query, all you
need is the ID of the
product-- so,
content.googleapis et cetera
slash v1 slash your merchant
ID and ending in
the product ID.
That's the only ID
you would need--
it's equivalent to the rel
equals edit link when you're
normally dealing
with products.
And then you just submit batch
operation type equals query--
so it's just like that, but
rather than type equals delete
for delete, it's type
equals query.
And in order to get the
performance data, the batch
API URI actually will take the
same performance dot start,
and performance dot end
query parameters.
So you're actually able to, with
those query parameters,
get the same data you'd get via
the get request that you
can get through the batch URI.
So the next question, also from
Andrew in Sunnyvale, says
are there plans to expose views
or paid views attribute?
And Andrew goes on to say,
it would be helpful in
distinguishing between good
products with bad metadata and
bad products with good metadata
that have the same
number of clicks.
Now this is something--
views or impressions--
is something that we've had
requested a lot, and it's
something we're constantly
trying to figure out the best
way to service them.
So right now I have nothing to
announce and nothing to say
definitively whether yes or no
they will be exposed, but it's
something we're always
considering.
So thanks for bringing it up,
Andrew, and again, if people
really are wanting this, please
go to our shopping
issues list and vote this up or
come to the forum and give
us your opinions.
We'd love to hear them.
And the final question is from
[? StrackJS ?], John
[? Strackton, ?]
near London, and it asks is
there a batch option for
performance data?
Now, I've just answered this
question inadvertently by
answering Andrew's question.
So if you want to get
performance data in batch, you
could just use the same query
parameters, like I mentioned,
and I'll work on documenting
this.
And once I do have the
documentation for it complete,
I'll point everyone to where
it's been documented and I'll
make a post about
it on our forum.
So if we have no more questions
in our moderator
queue, I'm going to end.
So I'll see everybody in two
weeks from today, August 30,
and thanks for submitting your
questions and I hope the new
PaidClicks attribute
is helpful to you.
Have a nice day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]